nos dicen reescribe la siguiente
ecuación en forma logarítmica y tengo
0.01 esto es igual a 10 elevado a la
menos 2 y bueno esencialmente si lo que
queremos es escribir la misma
información pero ahora en una forma
logarítmica lo que tengo que pensar es
lo siguiente entonces a que potencia
necesitamos elevar el 10 para que nos dé
0.01 y bueno la respuesta es menos 2 y
por lo tanto lo vamos a escribir de la
siguiente manera el logaritmo en base 10
el logaritmo en base 10 de 0.01 ok a qué
potencia tengo que llevar el 10 para que
me dé 0.01 y bueno nosotros sabemos que
esto es igual a menos 2 ok
de esta forma estoy escribiendo la misma
expresión pero en el lenguaje en su
forma logarítmica el logaritmo en base
10 de 0.01
es lo mismo que menos 2 porque 10
elevado a la menos 2 es lo mismo que
0.01 10 elevado a la menos 2 es lo mismo
que 0.01 a que potencia tengo que elevar
el 10 para que me dé 0.01 bueno esto es
igual a menos 2 aquí está en forma
exponencial y aquí en forma logarítmica
y lo que quiero hacerte notar es lo
siguiente estoy escribiendo a justo aquí
la base cuando yo pongo un bajo y
después la base a la cual no voy a tomar
el logaritmo y por lo tanto ya está la
solución ya la tenemos justo aquí mi
solución es que esta expresión se ve
como el logaritmo en base 10 de 0.01 y
esto es igual a menos 2 ahora nos piden
reescribe la siguiente ecuación pero
esta vez en forma exponencial y justo lo
que me dicen es esto el logaritmo en
base 7 de 191 1.322 bueno esto es igual
a 2.7 ahora recuerda lo siguiente
recuerda que esto lo podemos leer de la
siguiente manera
en la que tenemos que elevar el 7 para
que nos den 191.300 22
es lo mismo que 2.7 o dicho de otra
manera y lo podemos escribir así 7 si lo
elevamos a la potencia 2.7 ok esto nos
tiene que dar exactamente lo mismo que
191.300 22 191.300 22 y lo que quiero
que te des cuenta es que aquí tengo dos
formas de escribir lo mismo la primera
en forma exponencial 7 elevado a la
potencia 2.7 es lo mismo que 191.300 22
o también lo podemos escribir en su
forma logarítmica el logaritmo en base 7
de 191.300 22
es lo mismo que 2.7 y bueno es momento
de comprobar la respuesta y de lujo
estamos bien